we are inside this gym Hall in the
middle of ephrine in the Aleppo
Countryside this is where dozens of
Syrian families have taken shelter after
their homes were partially or totally
destroyed by the earthquake what we've
seen here can only be described as
devastating especially to children and
the elderly
let's hear now from one of the survivors
we have been sheltered in this hall for
12 days but we don't have any Services
we have not received any assistance I
suffer from colon cancer and back pain
I'm sleeping on this hard surface in
this fiercely cold weather it is really
tough
although we survived the earthquake we
find ourselves faced with another type
of disaster the walls of our house fell
on my wife and she has been in hospital
for 10 days she doesn't have anything
not even a mattress to sleep on we have
not received any medical Aid I'm a
father to four all of them was suffering
from a constant cough some health
organizations came over but could not
even provide a cough medication
it's nothing but harsh living conditions
that these families are left to battle
tragic stories can be heard wherever we
go
these survivors are in need of food
shelter and medical supplies we've heard
similar complaints in every area we've
been to people in desperate need of help
although dozens of trucks have passed
the northern border more relief Aid is
needed the lack of services and
shortages of supplies is all we hear and
see here on the ground in Northwestern
Syria
Aleppo Countryside